[Music]
well greetings dear friends
uh thank you for being with us i have
with me uh c.a murray
who has come out of the woodwork and
he's going to introduce our progress
today
it is good to be back in this chair um
it's good to be back to i'd like to know
good to be back at
secrets unsealed pastor and and good to
be back you know
you you sort of jump in with both feet
here when you you don't
you don't get time to sort of ease your
way back in
but it's a it's a wonderful experience
we've always enjoyed doing this program
together amen i certainly have and um
so it's nice uh to do this again this of
course is i'd like to know it is our
question and answer program where we try
by the grace of god to answer your
bible-based questions
from the word of god and we have always
made you that promise
that we would do so and uh we'd like to
invite you to be to be a part of this
program we've got a pile of questions
and we can always use more if you'll
write to tv at some tv.org
we will get your questions and we will
wrestle with your questions
and hopefully by the grace of god bring
you an answer from the word of god amen
uh to your questions
so pastor it's good to be back good to
sit across the table from you
and i know we've got a a bunch of
questions to do with today
i am delighted to have you back now my
work is cut in half
and also because it's good to have a
good friend back but
let's have a word of prayer and then i
have a question which you know
people might entertain yeah it's a real
real life
sad somewhat question so let's pray
father in heaven
we thank you for the privilege now of
dedicating these few minutes to
answering some questions we ask for the
guidance of your holy spirit
i ask lord that you will bring comfort
to all of those who are watching i know
many are suffering
not only because of the virus but
they're suffering family issues and
economic issues and health issues
i just ask lord that you will come close
to them and you'll bring comfort
and assurance in this difficult time and
so be with us now
as we try to answer these questions we
pray in jesus name
amen amen amen okay ca i have this
question
and i'm just going to read it my nephew
committed suicide
mid-may 2021 he was a sick young man
trying to deal with mental illness
and now comes the question do suicides
automatically
suffer the second death my pastor said
god takes the entire life
into consideration this is a difficult
time
and i trust the knowledge of secrets
unsealed
so that is the big question yes
you know we were talking just a little
bit before the program
the part that stands out to me is the
word automatically
i i don't think anything is automatic
with god
uh in his dealing with the human family
christ died to save us god is trying to
get as many in
as possible there are any number of
variables that come
into this thing first of all did the
person know jesus
uh was the person a follower of christ
was their life surrendered to christ
if that was so then god can deal with
the mental decline
a little differently than a person who
did not follow christ
so you know you've got a lot of
variables in addition to
the just the suicide uh
you know that you have to weigh in and
that god certainly will take into
account
you know the bottom line is that we
don't know
really whether the individual
has the capacity to really understand
what the person is doing
i'm glad that i'm not the judge amen i'm
glad that god is the judge
because god is going to take everything
into consideration
the mental capacity of the individual
etc
having said that ellen white has several
interesting comments about
the issue of suicide yes she mentions
those who who were wicked and who were
selfish
will come forth in the second
resurrection she also
mentions the name of an individual pilot
and i just read that statement three
spirit of prophecy 146
uh his honors this is after he sent
jesus to be crucified his honors were
stripped from him
he was cast down from his high office
and stung by remorse and wounded pride
he committed suicide not long after the
crucifixion
yes so he's going to resurrect in the
second resurrection she also deals with
people who had
bad health habits and that led them to
commit suicide
however she does have a statement where
she says that people who
have been contemplating suicide there
is a way in which their heart can be
changed
by the lord so that they they don't uh
take their own life yes
uh so i was surprised that the number of
times that ellen white mentioned suicide
there's uh 32 references including
duplications uh regarding this
particular issue
so anyway i wish that i could say one
way or the other with
this relative but one thing that we're
sure of
and that is whatever decision god makes
we will agree that it was the right
decision that god made because god knows
the end from the beginning yes
god is much wiser than we are uh he
knows
everything he knows what the mental
condition of the individual was
their trajectory etc and so we just need
to leave it in the lord's hands
and we will get a chance uh during the
thousand year period to go over and see
that those decisions that god made were
fair and just and right
uh and good one and again god is trying
to
christ went to the cross to get as many
in as possible right if god can get him
in without breaking any rules laws or
commandments
he will do so because he loves us just
that much what about those pastor you
know
who are committing suicide with their
knife and fork almost every day
you know well ellen white does have a
statement about that
she calls it slow suicide
[Laughter]
maybe i can i can read this it's
spiritual gifts volume 4 page 128.
she's speaking about tobacco here quebec
was the poison of the most deceitful and
malignant kind
wow having an exciting then a paralyzing
influence upon the nerves of the body
it is all the more dangerous because of
its effects upon the system
its effects upon the system are so slow
and at first scarily perceivable
multitudes have fallen victims to its
poisonous influence
they have surely murdered themselves by
the slow poisons yes
and we ask what will be their waking
in the resurrection morning
[Music]
and then she has this other statement
since writing the above i learned that
most
of thoughts on the revelation she's
talking about uri smith who
wrote the book thoughts on the
revelation was written in the night
after the author's day's work was done
this was the course which my husband
pursued
i protest against such suicide
so overworking and i believe that uriah
smith and james white will be saved
because you know probably they repent it
from over taxing
their system by overwork she also
mentions
intoxicating liquor testimonies to
ministers 457 the use of intoxicating
liquors is on the increase
many who have followed their own
unsanctified
will seek to end their unprofitable
lives by suicide so
she's saying that drinking uh can cause
people to to commit suicide
yeah and you can literally work yourself
to death i mean
james had um five strokes uh
he didn't work too long and too hard and
i remember her telling um
joseph bates the lord has released you
he told you to stop now
because you're working too hard and you
just need to and you're right smith said
well eric smith
was kind of a hard-headed guy he's very
difficult to deal with but
he again a nighthawk working into the
night yeah and you can you can't burn
the candle at both ends that is suicide
yeah and traveling and traveling and
traveling and at that time you didn't
get on
the jet no sir and be in new york in
five hours
you have to cross the country by train
yes sir that took several days
several days uh so what we need to do is
make sure that we keep our health
uh in good shape eating properly
and by exercising and getting sunshine
just following the eight laws of health
yes because that way our mental
health will be stronger and we won't
even be tempted to commit suicide yes
okay here's another interesting one
i had never heard anyone ask this
question before but it's excellent
i would like to know if on the new earth
freedom of choice will still exist
i understand that sin will not be
repeated
all looking at the signs in the palms of
the savior
in other words sin is not going to arise
again because they'll look at the
runes that jesus had but the freedom of
choice
in obeying or not will there be such a
thing
i would like some evidence in the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
some brothers and sisters consider that
the freedom of choice will not exist
in the new earth because satan and sins
were destroyed
in my understanding the freedom of
choice will continue for eternity
but i don't have the proof thank you for
helping me
um you know i think one of the
the bedrock principles of the
law of god of the government of god
might be better said is
the freedom of choice i don't see
anywhere in the word of god that says
throughout the eternity that will be
changed it will be more
our drawing closer to the lord more our
contemplation of the sacrifice that he
made
more of viewing the wounds that are lit
yet
remain that will insulate us can i say
against going back to the sinful life
as opposed to turning us into what we've
never been and that's been
a robot uh before the lord yeah
yeah you know um the bottom line is
that the angels in heaven before this
world was created had freedom of choice
even though they lived in a perfect
heaven
where there was no sin and there was no
satan at that point
and they had freedom of choice because
they made the wrong choice yes
uh adam and eve had freedom of choice in
the garden of eden god placed the tree
they said don't eat from the tree and
that was in a perfect garden before sin
so why wouldn't there be freedom of
choice
in the earth made new eden restored yes
even though there is no satan and
there's no sin
right there's never been a time when
there's not been freedom of choice
it's always been freedom right there
couldn't be love if there wasn't freedom
of choice correct
here i have a very interesting statement
from ellen white
where she describes the wounds on the
body of christ
as being what you mentioned the security
of the universe
as we observe the sacrifice that jesus
made
this is great controversy 647. as the
ransomed ones
are welcome to the city of god yes their
rings out upon the air an exultant
cry of adoration the two atoms are about
to meet
the son of god is standing without
stretched arms to receive the father of
our race
the being whom he created who sinned
against his maker
and for whose sin the marks of the
crucifixion are born upon the
born upon the savior's form as adam
discerns the prince of the cruel nails
he does not fall upon the bosom of his
lord but in humiliation casts himself at
his feet
crying worthy worthy is the lamb that
was slain
tenderly the savior lifts him up and
bids him
look once more upon the eden home
from which he has so long been exiled
and you know also i remember w d for z
used a very good illustration
in his book ransom and reunion in the
sanctuary he was the founder of wildwood
institute
[Music]
and he said you know if every time you
were going to commit this sin
you had to drive nails through your
mother's hands what would you do drive
the nails or you quit the sin
the answer's obvious yeah and so he says
you know sin we need to see how much
sin hurts the one that we love
and then we will want to cease sinning
yeah
yeah you know when you look at it sort
of pragmatically pastor
what guarantee do i have that sin will
not rise a second time
the only guarantee i have is because god
who knows then from the beginning
said it's not going to happen you know
that's
i i can't i see today i can
guess about tomorrow that's the limit of
my vision
but the lord who knows all and sees all
down through eternity
said it's not going to happen well
that's good enough for me
yeah yeah and you know the fact that you
mentioned that it's not going to rise
again
brings to mind a verse that we use quite
frequently nahum
chapter 1 and verse 9. and ellen white
quotes that verse in great controversy
and i'd like to read that statement
because it goes back to what you
mentioned about
the universe being secure forever as
they see the great sacrifice that jesus
made
this is after the millennium the wicked
are gathered outside the city all the
righteous are inside the city
and the panorama has been shown above
the city showing that god is loving and
god is just
and that's the context of this statement
the whole universe
will have become witnesses to the nature
and results of sin
and its utter extermination which in the
beginning would have brought fear to
angels
and dishonor to god will now vindicate
his love
and establish his honor before the
universe of beings
who delight to do his will and in whose
heart
is his law never will evil again be
manifest
amen says the word of god now she quotes
nahum 1 verse 9
affliction shall not rise up the second
time
the law of god which satan has
reproached as the yoke of bondage
will be honored as the law of liberty
and now comes the portion that i really
uh goes to what you mentioned a tested
and proved creation will never again
be turned from allegiance to him whose
character has been
fully manifested before them as
fathomless love
and infinite wisdom amen and amen so you
know
test tested and proved creation who
in his right mind would ever want to
experiment with sin again
after seeing what it cost yes yes yeah
so
so actually god allowing all this to
happen is the inoculation or vaccination
of the universe
yes yes yes i like that terminology
it works it does it does okay so anyway
uh let's notice um another question
there are several here this is an
interesting one
please what is the difference between
the seraphim with six wings in isaiah 6
verse 2
and revelation 4 6 through 8 where the
four living creatures
have six wings but in ezekiel one verses
five and six the four living creatures
have four wings and also in ezekiel 10
verse 1
it says that he has four wings
so how do we relate the four wings to
the six wings
um probably the we should read the texts
the only texts that speak of seraphim in
the bible which would be isaiah chapter
six
and verses one to three uh describes the
seraphim in the old testament this is
the only reference in the old testament
to
seraphim okay this is the call of isaiah
i am there you want verse 61
one through three oh one through three
okay isaiah 6
1 in the year the king as i had died i
saw the lord sitting on the throne
high and lifted up and the train of his
robe filled the temple
above it stood seraphim each one having
six wings
with two he covered his faith faith with
two he covered his feet
and with two he flew and one cried
uh to another and said holy holy holy
is the lord of hosts the whole earth is
full of his glory
that's one two and three okay so so
the seraphim there have how many wings
this is six
the seraphim have six wings and in
revelation chapter 4 and 5
the living creatures have six wings
so we assume that in revelation chapter
4 and 5
we're dealing with seraphim as well but
the question is
in ezekiel chapter 1 and ezekiel chapter
the cherubim have four wings
so are the cherubim and now the seraphim
two different orders of being
in heaven two different orders of angels
if you please
well do we have any spirit of prophecy
counsel on that we do
you know several years ago i did a study
of ellen white's
comments on the seraphim and you know i
have about five pages here of quotations
but i'll just summarize
uh some of the content first of all
there are three orders of beings
this is a short statement from god's
amazing grace page 58.
ellen white wrote in fact the fact that
the law is holy just and good
is to be testified before all nations
tongues and peoples
and then it says two worlds unfallen
two angels seraphim
and cherubim so she makes a distinction
between
angels seraphim cherubim and the world's
unfallen she also mentions that there
are ranks
of angels in heaven uh which is
she says and the angelic host angels and
archangels
covering cherub and gloria seraph echo
back
the refrain of that joyous triumphant
song saying amen blessing and honor
and glory etc to the lamb so she
mentions here angels and archangels
covering cherub and glorious
seraph so there's different orders of
angels
she also says that the highest order of
angel out of the seraphim
i used to think it was a cherubim but
she says it's a seraphim
desire of ages 785 from the highest
seraph to the humblest animate being
all are replenished from the source of
life and i'll just summarize some of the
others
there are common angels and seraphs and
they are different
satan was once this is an interesting
one satan was once both
a seraph and a cherub
now i haven't been able to explain how
that works out
but she wrote in great controversy 669
satan seems this
he's outside the city at the end of the
millennium satan seems paralyzed
as he beholds the glory and majesty of
christ
he who who was once a covering cherub
remembers where he has fallen a shining
seraph
son of the morning now changed now
degraded
so and then she also says some of the
angels who fail with lucifer were
seraphim
uh the seraphim are guardians of god's
throne
they do not glory in themselves their
only purpose is to glorify god
the seraphs fit humans for their mission
they will escort god's people into the
holy city
when the city descends after the
millennium wow in fact
this is a powerful statement she's
speaking about the resurrection of the
righteous
when they awake the pain is all gone oh
grave where is thy victory
here they stand and the finishing touch
of immortality is put upon them
and they go up to meet their lord in the
air the gates of the city
of god swing back upon their hinges and
the nations that have kept the truth
enter in
and then comes this interesting comment
there are the columns of angels on
either side
cheering on the righteous yeah that's
incredible and the ransom of god
walk in through the cherubim
and seraphim christ bids them welcome
and puts upon them his benediction well
done thou good and faithful servant
enter thou into the joy of thy lord what
is that joy
he sees of the travail of his soul and
is satisfied
that is what we labor for
she also mentions that the seraphim are
obedient strictly obedient to the god's
orders
and they're swift to fulfill god's
commands
and then there's this my favorite of all
is where she describes the wonder of the
universe as they contemplate
the final remnant and its faithfulness
to god it says the lord jesus
is making experiments on human hearts
through the exhibition of his mercy and
abundant grace
he is affecting transformations so
amazing that satan with all his
triumphant boasting
with all his confederacy of evil united
against god and the laws of his
government
stands viewing them as a fortress
impregnable
to his sophistries and delusions they
are to him an incomprehensible mystery
the righteous at the end of time that's
powerful the angels of god
seraphim and seraphim the powers
commissioned
to cooperate with human agencies look
on with astonishment and joy
that fallen men once children of wrath
are through the training of christ
developing characters
after the divine similitude to be sons
and daughters of god
to act an important part in the
occupations
and pleasures of heaven powerful isn't
that a powerful statement it is
very much so so we're made a spectacle
spectacle to the universe according to
the apostle paul
yes in first corinthians 4 9. i always
knew of
satan as the cherub that covereth
that statement of a ceremony i just i
probably have read it before but
it hasn't stuck in my brain until just
now
uh that's one of the ones we're going to
ask the lord about like
i think so i've tried to reconcile how
he could be a seraph
and a cherub because it maybe the wings
have to do more with function
yeah than with physical characteristics
because maybe uh
lucifer who became satan maybe he
fulfilled both roles
when he was in the presence of god could
very well be but
once we get there we'll be able to ask
the lord yeah and find out what
what the true scoop is
[Laughter]
so anyway well our time is leaving
pretty quickly
we have a statement here
actually it's a question based on a
lecture that i gave a while back
i have heard you say that job 38 verse 7
uh where it says the sons of god shouted
for joy and the stars of heaven saying
saying yes i have heard you say that job
38 verse 7 applies to the angels
and all the sons of god keeping the
first sabbath
how do you prove that job 38 verse 7
refers to the sabbath because it is not
explicit if it can be proven would it be
a good argument that adam kept the first
sabbath
along with his creator so
uh let's go to job and this has to be
pretty quick because time is flying by
uh job chapter
38 and uh
let's read verses one through seven real
quick 38 1-7
if you want to read that ca actually
let's read beginning
at verse four verse four
where were you when i lay the
foundations of the earth
tell me if you have understanding who
determined its
measurements surely you know or
who stretched the line upon it to what
were its foundations
fastened that's the verse six or
who lay the count its cornerstone when
the morning stars sang together
and all the sons of god shouted for joy
so
what event is being described in these
verses there's no doubt that it's
describing creation
god laid the foundations of the earth he
determined its measurements
he stretched the line upon it uh
you know he laid its cornerstone and
then it says that when this happened
the morning stars sang together and all
the sons of god
shouted for joy yes and so it's obvious
that all
heaven celebrated at creation
now did the heavenly beings also
celebrate
the sabbath you know the sabbath was a
day for god to contemplate
his work and to marvel at his work and
he wanted human beings to do the same
yes
in the book desire of ages page 769
ellen white wrote in the beginning the
father
and the son had rested upon the sabbath
after their work of creation and then
she goes on when the heavens and the
earth were finished
and all the host of them the creator
and all the heavenly beings rejoiced
in contemplation of the glorious scene
then she quotes job 38 verse 7
the morning star sang together and all
the sons of god shouted for joy
so all the whole heaven celebrated
that sabbath yes in the contemplation of
the marvelous works
of god well you could you could expect
no less than all of heaven uh
to be excited over this brand new order
of creation amen this brand new world
of br two brand new beings uh this is
exciting stuff
everybody's in on that party praise the
lord praise god
well our time is just about up we want
to thank you for tuning in to our
program i'd like to know
there's a program that airs every
tuesday 4 30 in the afternoon pacific
time
we hope you'll join us next time for
this special question and answer program
i'd like to know
[Music]
you